comment ça se passe pour les scènes de
sexe est-ce que c'est pas trop gênant d'
non c'est assez chouette en fait ouais
non moi j'adore ça c'est ce que je
préfère question qui doit revenir
souvent aussi parce que ah oui ouai mais
oui mais c'est c'est marrant déjà ça
crée un truc dans l'équipe là là il y a
toute une équipe autour aussi mais quand
il y a ce genre de scène tout le monde
prend des position un peu de Rodin quoi
comme le penseur comme ça genre
lesissant l'intime aux acteurs moi j'ai
beaucoup de fourir nerveux quand même
donc je toujours comme si j'étais à
l'aise mais en fait il quand même je
sens bien que je rigole trop et que ce
n'est pas normal c'est stressant quand
même il y a une forme de ouais c'est
stressant ça fait peur ouais ça fait
peur mais je suis toujours arrivé à à
discuter avec les les les les les
acteurs à qui je fait ça ou les actrices
on est vraiment ensemble là-dedans et on
cherche des choses et c'est pas
inintéressant hein